After all these year
there is nothing
until today.
All these signs,
something bigger.
Maybe this is the
point to all of this.
This show is a drama
set against the backdrop
of a massive alien
invasion of earth.
One of the goals we
had of this show
is to immerse the
audience in a visceral,
emotional, intense
survival situation.
We need to get home.
The whole world is falling apart
and its affecting people
in different ways everywhere,
it's incredible.
It's amazing to see
how the characters
evolved through this show
They’re battling the elements,
and Trevante a navy seal,
I mean he’s seen a lot of stuff.
Hello!
But to experience the fact that
the world’s been invaded,
that’s new for everybody.
Invasion is a story
about family.
It’s a story about our
shared humanity.
All of our characters
are outsiders,
dealing with their own
version of alienation.
We wanted all of
these emotional stories,
magnified by this
global traumatic event.
To be able to see the
different vantage points
but everything is
interconnected,
the show is incredible.
They’re here to take us.
This is a very interesting show.
It’s much more
than simple sci-fi.
Come on now!
We don’t know what it wants.
I think it's something
you’ve never seen before.
It’s super cool.
It’s the mystery;
it’s what you don’t know.
That’s a scary thing.
[heavy breathing]
[slam] [screams]